Coco yeah you guys can clap you guys can
clap people holding cameras back there
not clapping oh we're very excited today
thank you guys for joining us we are
with dimes the number one draft pick and
the NBA 2k league which starts May 1st
twitch TV twitch TV / NBA 2k league and
we're gonna play NBA 2k 18 which is
amazing because I am terrible at this
game as I am and all games but very
terrible at this game uh so welcome guys
uh I was saying a lot of the chat it
wasn't long that's right
that's right everybody everybody's
loving everybody's loving you so this is
amazing you are you're the number one
draft pick the NBA and 2k combined
forces like some kind of crazy Voltron
ask beast to make a league in esports
league to play NBA 2k and you are the
number one guy I was a pressure no
pressure no pressure what it's crazy you
have your so we were talking for a
little bit ago you have the dream job
for 99 percent of the people watching
the other 1% are Call of Duty players
and they're talking to but that's as to
say how did it all start for you how did
you first kind of start playing NBA 2k10
it all start yeah so I always had a
passion for basketball in general and to
kids basketball so it went Hanahan and
we always come home from school play NBA
2k wear them or gloss on a hoop it was a
gloss added who play NBA 2k we were
always playing basketball on subway so
and sometimes playing both you would
hoop with one hand and then you have the
controller in the other hand which is
amazing that's I can't believe when
everything yeah it's incredible
don't try that you're hurt yourself kids
do you remember the first time you play
an NBA 2k like the very first time so it
you were like what do you playing it's
always like no why are you playing with
Mickey Mouse but is yeah I don't
remember the very first time but I
remember playing if you into if you were
to explain or give advice to people who
want to be where you are now what would
you say
so to anybody out there who
you know wants to be a professional
gamer it doesn't have to be 2k it could
be any game or whatever stardew valley
perhaps perhaps a professional stardew
valley player yeah just uh just keep
playing you're gonna have to put the
work and put the time in is the most
important thing and just learning the
game just learning every little thing
about it uh for me the biggest obstacle
was my parents always tell me like hey
man you know you got to do something you
got to get a job you got to do something
like I'm like yo dad like right yeah
exactly yeah playing a game like I'm I'm
working toward something and you know
just bear with me for a while exactly it
actually wasn't until last year someone
I want to turn him into where he finally
led up like because he saw Abra here's
some real money that's amazing all right
we're gonna play this is the probably
the dumbest thing I've ever done but I'm
gonna try to play against you so prepare
everyone and hope people are laughing
the back and that's fun that's the
appropriate response and I'm hoping
you'll kind of teach me as well I'm
hoping a little earn from getting my ass
severely beat and I'm just saying
earlier I am a Pistons fan but I like
choosing the sweatiest looking guy right
there
hey can you move us into the middle of
me I like choosing this sweatiest dude
Hardin is pretty sweaty here
part of it is I think he's wearing a
sweater on his face he's got a big beard
which I'm a bit jealous of medium what's
a medium sweaty beard no that's okay
fair I'm just sweating normally I just
have a glandular problem so beard or not
I'm just always moist now you you
actually play for the maps you play for
the Mavericks that's and were you
drafted by the Mavs are traded to the
Mavs
oh man that's crazy because sometimes
they build drafting and trade for other
I'm going I'm gonna go I'm not Westhoff
so maybe you should do the West
all-stars I'm good you're gonna kill me
anyway
what are we even talking about I get the
slit I guess that's the sweatiest team
living it's so sweaty and has
be honest I'm not even gonna try that
again
giannis it's a cool those are the other
letters I can't get rid of in Scrabble
it's amazing all right really good I'm
going West all-stars we're gonna see how
good you really are
times that's right exactly I'm ready to
see Aaron loose terribly that's correct
Madeline Sims that is the proper
response a honey blur say what if I lose
sad then what if you lose a comet is
gonna destroy this thing there's about
as much okay so what do we have to do we
just I just hit I love this one thing I
love too is it's it's crazy that like
basketball and like 2k have become
closer and closer together in terms of
like when you watch on TV it looks like
you're watching the game and vice versa
yeah when you're watching and even like
yeah the graphics are great it's insane
it's unbelievable it's gonna it's gonna
come to the point to where and then
we'll be able to control that's my dream
that's to control other people I want to
be the puppet master pull the strings so
wait so you had to go like just like in
bat and in in basketball you had to go
through a combine yes and so so explain
to people what a combine is first of all
if we don't sports fans and then kind of
how it went for you okay so the combine
is basically where you go to showcase
your talents showcase your skills and
show everybody why you should be in the
NBA or the NBA League and so it's the
kind of it's it's - uh everybody has to
do the same test so it's it's a
benchmark it's been creating a benchmark
for every player the teams to kind of
agree do you want I guess yes right yes
so so for the combine that we have to do
is start off with the 72,000 people
Jesus God yeah a pretty pretty big
number and um so first we had some wind
50 games so that's pretty simple
see the times it's simple that's very
simple no free just the casual players
I'm like I'm still working on my first
but fine so you just got to get 50 wins
and so you qualify for the combine and
and the 70 mm - you got the 50 wins once
at a combine and you play games and it
was like scheduled dates and what times
timeframes that you can play good Lord
and when you were matched up with random
people are yes so you might some with
random people like people who has a
little scam people who have never played
the game they just heard about the
League of the plants like American Idol
you have the people are just so yeah you
know what next year by the way next year
probably will be it I show via TV so
absolutely but um so yeah you go into
there and you playing with random people
sometimes you get good teammates and
sometimes you just get the worst of the
crop and what if you get somebody
terrible how I could that that's
obviously gonna affect you and your
staff yeah of course so you just not
pass the ball and I just try to fight
through it try to teach them the best I
can you know just trying to put my team
the best position to win because I write
I saw I read an article about you he's
very complimentary and it had two
screenshots it said one of the greatest
things about dimes is the fact he'll
have a game like this and it's just like
a bajillion points in all my stuff or a
game like this and zero points in like
55 assists just like you know exactly
you're you're you're 18 you're you want
to play for the team exactly you're good
team player well I'm a point guard so
you know we are jobless to get our team
in yeah as much as possible that's true
exactly I just take whatever a defense
given whether they're leaving me wonder
why I'm gonna come on defender and all
right we'll see how you do with your
team right now cuz you're gonna play
against me let's do it how do we uh
start yeah just my line note but try
hard do I have to pick guys here oh that
should miss right now okay that's all
right great
there we go perfect I got I got my
favorite dealer in here great can I just
can I just play he's just I'm just gonna
press Start
I made of action dimes I like action and
I like a lot of shooting
from half-court so we're gonna see a lot
of that well you got come here Glynn my
guide dimes that's right if you guys
have questions for diastole uh uh hit
about what's that he's actually a part
of Madison gaming Oh awesome
he's like whoa I like in another skill I
don't have there's a lot of skills I
don't have including good smelling
breath and I'm sorry about that
yes exactly uh yeah Rick the gamer I
think we got some in times sometimes
people in the chat oh here we go alright
also I turned off the music for the it's
not as exciting now we're gonna get into
some sweet excitement oh oh I love this
I love ya tweak it exactly how you want
so tell us about your tell us about your
character you're a six five point guard
right huh I'm a six five a shot-maker
shot maker alright so that's like a shot
creator and play maker combined awesome
and and how would you describe your
playing style as it relates to players
who play the lead so I always say that
my player the way I play is a
combination between Kyrie Irving nice
and uh fashion is and like dribbling
yeah and aspect of just passing and
pick-and-roll in handsomeness
cp3 very handsome man I though my
goodness such dreamy eyes those Chris
Paul's eyes are dreamy eyes oh you I
mean your dreamy eyes - I'm trying not
to look directly into them cuz I might
fall in love so look how love might
happen on this this treatment represent
the land dimes I love it yeah by the way
I love this filthy spit like with Phil
that's the least I love like a guy named
Phil be like it hey my name's Tommy
facility
we're talking about cool names how did
you how did you originally come up with
dimes so I can move with mimes it just
fits so I'll always play a basketball my
whole life
yeah and I was a little bit more shape
yeah we all were very back then we're
also abroad I'm actually very good at
basketball numb like my aspect has
always been to pass the ball like this
what I love to do yeah and I do the same
thing in real life I always estimate
flashy passes I love it I'm just pretty
pretty flashy in them it just those
Hanahan and actually a cool thing is m2k
when I make a shot or something or three
or a big shot or a big nut they say
dimes dude oh my god dude that is bucket
list for me yeah it's amazing okay yeah
I'm ready let's do it let's do it all
right let's do I was in I'm in two of
the GTA games well you stole it
oh there we go look at this all right
now let's get in here I'm just I thought
I was passing okay square is shoot yeah
I've told this story many times in the
chat but I got my voice harden up here
there we go a little Oh get in there
this is the only time I'm gonna be ahead
by the way I paid times $20 to let me
score before we started there's too many
guys in the Quartus this as many as many
people as should be on here I feel like
there's no K all right I'm gonna let you
have that one exactly is jail B gonna be
on strict to you also Rebs Germany I
don't know what that means
[Music]
so you so you got drafted by the Mavs
yeah that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
we've done a couple shows in Dallas and
it's always so great the food I love
down there man oh that barbecue when is
Dallas Rudy's Dallas we're fat Matt's
rib check is that's Atlanta we also did
shows in Atlanta which was also amazing
barbecue I'm a salty guy that a sweet
guy I mean really doughnuts are great
but like crunchy Cheetos are like my
crack cocaine like to you I can I could
smell it an open bag a spreadsheet even
oh no it's not sweet crunchy Cheetos
aren't sweet is not sweet times I have a
very important question for you okay do
you prefer puffs or crunchy when it
comes to Cheetos
prefer crafts and puffs or crunchy okay
so this is going to determine our
friendship not a huge ceiling okay fair
enough no harder my man thank God cuz
this dream is about to be over I almost
ended this dream right like the reed oh
yeah Oh Joey knows I'm a fan
I want them to sell the Cool Ranch stuff
just as something I could put on
everything okay yeah yeah oh my gosh oh
geez
nacho cheese is great you know what's
your opinion of these all these new
upstart flavors you know they got like
like these knockos supreme or you know
like all that stuff yeah yeah classic a
man that was a terrible pass there was
you know what I wanted to do I wanted
there seemed like a sick child in the
audience and so I wanted to give them
the ball till they they can remember
this game for us yeah right
I jump into the crowd you you guys are
just joining us with dimes the number
one draft pick the NBA 2k league NBA 2k
league starts May 1st on Twitter the
move baby to me is gonna be crazy
amazing dice plays for the Dallas Mavs
and he's currently destroying me not
really but the game is all we've been
waiting for the minute and a half
oh there we go Oh get in there come on
come on what did I will say I do like
about NBA 2k is its it does even the
playing field very well for somebody
who's not a skilled player you don't
have to be that's one thing I'm not even
mad and fan you know if you play Madden
it's it's it's really it's so
complicated I which is great it's a very
deep game but it doesn't it doesn't do a
great job for me as an unskilled player
unlike NBA 2k does a great job of like
here you suck we're gonna make we're
gonna help you out and have guys block
it's a pretty yeah it's a view to learn
how it's a mess exactly very simple bit
deep
unreal oh yeah so what's your what is
your now you so when you got drafted you
know you got put with the team of people
you didn't know
do you guys have a coach to you where I
mean you practice like how does that go
what is you take us through your day so
our day is now John Edwards great shout
out Jonah no our days right now that's
crazy so practice is the biggest thing
just getting up to each other I mean
it's it's a sport so exactly like you
would if you got traded to or a new team
start get inside oh come on hard and use
that beard I don't know how he I'm just
hacking you I'm hacking you crazy though
these days you know the purple bag
Doritos are by far the best
what's purple what is that like glacier
fries we're not talking Gatorade man no
wait here I have a question are you to
have endorsements no more would you what
would be your dream endorsement of any
products I mean I'm glad would it be
classic Doritos would that be like I
mean obviously I know shoes are cool and
clothes and that stuff obviously you
want a Maserati or a Ferrari everybody
wants to be sponsored by that so here's
like this kind what do we do stilts how
hard is this guy try it not to rag on
your you know you're already dressed
like a horse
I know but you know but you got stilts
that's a tall horse man that's a very
tall boy it's not to go knock the ball
foul that's true right I guess he some
he is a maverick right so he's living
life on the edge there but he looks like
a horse who had like a leg surgery oh
it's like Matt Damon and Elise the other
- yeah exactly so what would be your
dream endorsement for those for all the
companies watching now and I know you
guys are all watching over me
all the okay fair enough okay I mean
anything to me very political very
political of you you're not gonna know
this out I need my splitter yeah
historian contact dat boy dimes the
Twitter and Instagram
hit him up give me any endorsements
exactly now what about like let's say
there's something a company wants to
endorse you but they're not super cool
let's say like they're like shoe inserts
like dr. Scholl's okay come to you
they're like dimes we love what you do
we want to endorse you what am I gonna
dr. Schultz is that a yes I'm gonna put
the phone exactly that's exactly yes
you're not gonna be chillin like
Magellan you're gonna be dr. Scholl's is
like you're gonna be role you're gonna
be rolling like Shoals in not gelling
like my job I would kind of love to see
you like do an endorsement of that and
like make it cool would be awesome and
dr. Scholl's if you're watching and this
is how you get into the youth demo
there's nothing cooler you have like you
have your own oh what am i doing no I
love that you're even watching my games
it's good you are teaching me though
that's good well purple is spicy sweet
chili Doritos I guess I'd get down with
that I don't know man you know like a
lot of hostile oh you're not a hot guy
okay so no note of it the sweet but not
the spicy you know what in recent years
I have gone very hot we did a thing our
whole office here at team Coco is
obsessed with hot sauces and so every
year we do a Christmas gift we send to
well obviously we send you krysta
but we do so we do Christmas gifts like
for people in the industry and we made
our own hot sauce called sick burn team
cocoa sick burn yeah and it was but you
don't I don't like I like I like flavors
not just heat you know like oh there we
go hello never leave me open never oh
wait sounds like you
yeah I guess
spicy and sweet I'm not to pick us I'll
be spicy you're sweet you know yeah I
mean I guess spicy sweets my personality
if I'm getting serious that's right
that's right that's right hey guys
chicken oh God comedy's oh no I was
checking out how many skulls I don't
know what happens Scoville level I'm up
- I don't do that we know - uh Weems do
Scoville levels I just do I put a little
on my tongue and I taste it you see
what's up let's see what's up
no wait no so do you guys when you
practice are you because the advantage I
would say or one thing that's very
different about to cave versus playing
on a court is you don't need to be in
the same location do you guys go - do
you have a warehouse or practicing you
have a practice area or do you all do it
from the house yeah for sure that's
awesome that's great
yeah because so when you're playing
these games are you playing in front of
an audience um we planned the enemy game
yeah yes all the time and games will
yeah that's crazy
that would be really nerve-racking I can
barely handle the fact there's like six
people in this room I don't like people
watching me do stuff you know like when
I go to the grocery store I just wear a
big black bag no I don't like to snow
because then the paparazzi's on me it's
a whole thing then you'll get it's just
it's gonna get annoying Chris yeah that
was great
oh look at that I want to give that
there's another sick kid in the auto I
was just trying to throw the ball really
exactly yes who lives you just join us
with dives number one draft pick n b8
okay League I [ __ ] go to NBA 2k league
calm to keep up with all the stuff
that's going on May 1st is when the
first game tips-off and what's your
schedule like do they give you your
schedule ahead of time um who you're
gonna be playing first you know no I
actually do not do you are you guys it's
so crazy because the thing that blows me
away about the NBA 2k league is the fact
that it's it's an actual sport you're
playing and so are you gonna watch tape
like do you watch other games definitely
definitely watch date that is so cool
you gotta know your plan you gotta know
their tendencies were thinking what to
do yeah it's it's amazing because it's
an emerging sport that I love it so but
it's also based on a sport that already
exists so you guys have a good blueprint
but desirey what's that feel like is
right is where an average I was that's
the where you two-minute NBA 2k majority
of the world knows what NBA is you can
just jump right in and it's exactly
right
that's exactly like watching yeah I know
that's the thing too is like again like
like you said I don't mean to distantly
alleges but I do think and one of the
reasons why I think the NBA 2k league is
so exciting is for that exact reason
people can just jump aboard and watch
and pick up a game versus having to have
this whole nomenclature of like and the
rules are all different for all those
different matches yeah yeah and so in
tournaments there are commentators and
all this stuff
what's crazy to me is and correct me I'm
wrong but during the draft out of SOPA
the NBA commissioner was there that's
crazy
were you nervous for that do you get you
don't get nervous ready
what's up Adam how we do so I wasn't so
in the really nervous uh to be honest I
was a little nerve we gotcha I knew it I
knew he liked my name finally being
caught because I previously got the call
from Mark Cuban little strange that's
insane
fun wait you mean shark tanks Mark Cuban
RC I'm just kidding this is the this is
the funny stories okay and then you had
an idea for a thing you pitched him and
now you have a swivel sweeper's side
business now dork so this is this is the
funny to concentrate did he leave you a
voicemail
no I actually got a text oh that's Roger
where she works with the okay cool and
um he's like dude answer your phone
sick Mark Cuban is coming I'm like the
genie Cuban is calling me it's like Mark
Cuban is calling you to tell you though
we're talking Bob you're like marvelous
year win the K some like some some my
hello and it's like hey what's going on
- this is Mark he's texting you for 2k
help he's like hey man I can't get past
it was actually crazy what kind of for
tonight oh my god really yeah Mark Cuban
actually tweeted out he was playing for
play mark oh my god that's another game
I'm terrible at I just keep my building
the building that's just that's the
still kept in the game that's the thing
that makes you that's a separate really
good
totally now what about let me just pitch
you a quick game and gay to cave but
with building so it's just like
fortnight and I you know to get across
the court I'm gonna build something you
know and you have to like jump over it
no I don't think yes no guys we're night
okay fort ball anyway horrible new thing
that's no uh no port my catalyst chad is
horrified no chad is definitely not into
fort ball cordon line with master Walker
yeah there we go
you gotta like shoot the ball into the
thing literally shoot the ball oh oh a
glorious bastard said basketball was
invented by a Canadian but we rejected
it for a real sport called hockey
oh please a real sport like hockey
although I will say you do wear knives
on your feet in hockey
I don't think that makes a real sport I
think that makes it a dangerous thing
you shouldn't do what real sport lets
you just punch each other in the face
come on it's ridiculous no I haven't
unfortunately but I hear it's great now
wait you're from Cleveland even though
you're playing for the Mavs who do you
root for when you want like what's it I
mean obviously I level a Bron I love a
LeBron situation how can you root
against LeBron I'm not gonna put you on
the spot okay but I will say this I
think I'll of LeBrons back in Cleveland
okay I am a Pistons man myself
okay and I said I think before we
started I only really did you just
totally destroy me in that move dude
but I'm only really a fair-weather fan I
kind of only watch when when they're
doing good I know no I know I'm a
terrible I look times I'm a terrible
person
I'm a terrible sports fan I really tried
to get into soccer okay cuz I was like
oh this game like the world right it's I
couldn't do it I just could I was
watching like Messi highlights on
YouTube I just couldn't I couldn't get
into it man
but what's crazy me it's like so I when
I lived I lived in New York for like
nine years okay and I bought a
billionaire Jersey you know and for
those who don't know Bill Laimbeer used
to playing the Pistons back in the
eighties I was growing up huge able the
guys like whatnot we start fights he was
like part of the Pistons bad boys guys
supremely hated by everyone so I'd wear
these shirt I wear this jersey to every
game everyone got a picture with me with
this land bridge because no one buys the
land beer Jersey cuz he's a jerk
but a great player would you like that
yeah I like this what happened was and
what amazed me is the Knicks fans so I
got all these Knicks games would root
against their own team is the crazy so I
would be like yeah go piss heads and
then like guys are like yeah like screw
the Knicks yeah go places of it and
everybody would start leaving and so as
the game would progressed like people
would leave it so we would just move
down and get better and better seats and
so one time we got so far down so many
Knicks fans and left that I just got to
sit right behind Fat Joe's that crazy
like the third row was amazing because
there was yeah how do you root against
your own team Knicks what are you doing
unless it's about them I know it's tough
so anyway I feel you with beat with your
love being split between the Cav's and
Mavs but of course unless they play each
other you can root for both there we go
just more love not less love I love by
the way I just looked at the score it's
44 18 that's depressing that's great oh
all right so break down my game here
what am I doing wrong
or should I say is it easier to say one
thing I'm doing okay see these are say
one thing I'm doing right
so not talking like an idiot and
blathering away like diarrhea of the
mouth
okay well okay now I have thrown tuned
into the crowd is that too many but it's
okay okay yeah okay thank you that's
cool
we're not that's not counting it's by
over 40 perfect what's your now what do
what is your when you first started game
do you have any superstitions yeah
before do you wear a certain or certain
socks or dr. Scholl's foot pads just
trying to help you out Neil an
endorsement I'll put this on okay sure
yes you put Scholz I'm guessing you put
shows in the shoes and then you got a
couple in your legs too because you know
they give them to you for free any
superstitions any like if you a crow
flies in front of you before a game you
walk in a different entrance or
something okay it's discipline man it's
the same it's it you're locked in like
you say you just focus yeah exactly do
you is there any kind of um do do people
try to distract you or talk smack or
anything to get in your head is that
true yes with these beautiful eyes who
who's gonna hate you gorgeous eyes
that's critical people actually do talk
a lot of smacks oh yeah oh my god do you
talk to my back you just you're above it
you take the high road
I lost my game game okay there we go
than this yeah you don't you're just
gonna lay down no oh look at that no
look past and right into the right into
the crowd GP gamer says diamond how is
it playing with their new team are you
guys confident
how you feeling right now that's moving
ahead a May first when NBA 2k league
starts on twitch.tv slashed NBA 2k so
yeah we're uh we're definitely confident
that's great you got to be got to become
you got to be confident and all that
kind of fear nobody we already played
whoever in uh whoever we messed up would
be ready
I love it dude this is great this is
great I know and you feel like you guys
are gelling pretty well
oh yeah as a team yeah definitely um
doing a lot of team bonding that's
awesome yeah actually I play a lot of
basketball in my life oh that's great so
yeah we actually have a that's oh my god
every night yes dude you guys are like I
love it
living and breathing basketball oh yeah
that's amazing
yeah like I said we have a passion for
right of course
and I think I think to get to the level
where you're at you have to have that
because it's just you're doing it so
much that it like I've always said like
you know for people who are trying to
get into television I've always said
like if you can quit doing TV quit it
because it's so hard and so intentional
and I'm sure that would be the same
thing for you like if you if you can go
a day without playing and if you can
decide to do something other than play
2k or play basketball do it because it
is it takes so much discipline a
motivation to get the level that you're
at that's I'm not gonna get any more
five-second violations they hate me cuz
they ain't me exactly exactly yeah do
you have eSports biz asks any pregame
music you have any jams turns to you
before that's a question yeah so right
now my fingers
I feel like that's something I would
call myself Erin Blair it would be a
buggy and I'm kind of upset that they
took my name that one to be honest I'm
yes a bookie I'm coming for you
so yeah that's my favorite rapper right
now but I listen to everything guys so I
literally like well gofyn which is a big
dude
Demi Lovato is a bogey you're a biggie a
boogie hey boogie I thought hell we got
a baby with I love it oh my god it's a
Demi Lovato yeah I love it like right
before keep my fingers
what's wrong with x he's like I know
he's just doing his Demi Lovato thing
don't worry people in tournaments like
final game after listening to like
person who listened to Demi Lovato
before you talk about me listening I
love that I love it I love people trying
to talk to smack about deep Avada and
you're just freaking get him inside get
him inside score a point please just do
the thing oh man a lot of John Grisham
audiobooks driving in the rain make I'm
just kidding um all right let's do right
now
no you know I'm into I mean I'm gonna
big Parliament phase right now problem
with Funkadelic I'm going back okay
I do like a good form on time I do
yes that's way before your time I do
like a good run too Jules
I love yeah I'm trying to thing is when
I met you right now and the roots I'm
really into the roots
you've heard the roots right oh my god
oh so old dimes I'm so oh look at these
claw these terrible withered claws
trying to play 2k some new stuff I mean
I mean you know I like Drake is fine his
drink oh I'm not some super news new
stuff guys no one is fine
I mean it's okay yeah you know like well
drink is a good one that's actually a
very good yeah you know I like what was
it boys before views if you're if you're
reading this it's too late oh my god
Lokhande said is this talking smack no
it's just literally I'm getting smack
talk by dial man oh it's even worse
you're hit times it's even worse when
you're hitting me
if the pity is worse than the I'm just
I'm sitting here in my dr. Scholl's you
know I got my holy man I'm so can
counter Fireblade for playing this
poorly yes exactly absolutely good I
know my boy my boy Oh fab and Celtics
crossover gonna make Cuban regret taking
your number one they're talking smack to
you ties whoo place is real right this
is real I mean how does a man like oh
I'm a big pop fan pop yeah you know I
like I'm trying to think of like I just
do I'll turn out like a Spotify if
there's like Spotify this will make you
feel old so it's like it's all music
I've never heard of I listen to a lot of
those t-swift although her new stuff
also is not great really are you ready
for it come on what are you doing not
good
the 1975 I like those guys oh no this is
so bad we were it wasn't my basketball
playing where I lost times respect it
was my music choices let the record show
I literally just threw that right to you
anyway I almost just handed you the ball
that's it that's one of the saddest
things I've ever seen in my life and
I've seen myself in the mirror many
times all right here we go here we go
get up there get up you know one thing
which is crazy is your reflexes have to
be on real to play these games like do
you do you do any this is kind of a dumb
question but do you do any stretching do
you do any are you doing any you guys do
stuff to get your reflexes keep them
tight
with me I don't do anything like that
when you sleep it's just you're doing
this you know you do with massive put
your hand up to the camera really good
can we get a full shot of this rep look
at look at how big I'm a big guy those
are huge this finger is crazy long that
fingers insane we figured out why you're
so good but you know what I will say you
know like you know like a basketball
player genetics do play a part and you
know having fast reflexes plays a huge
part you know definitely the - it's like
the game is yeah so it's like that's the
wrong yeah now I have a lot of hauntings
happening because I make a lot of
terrible decision JP gamer 201 says
times you worried you would go as the
number one pick you are supremely
confident reason being just because you
buy a basket this common and I would if
I could
because yeah I mean Marc Hume is not
calling everybody I still win here call
Marc and I don't appreciate that have a
lot of calls in your got some really
good Shark Tank ideas appreciate it
appreciate the club Marc yeah he's
happened that's so cool that's amazing
what would my baller nickname be Oh
dizzy death says Anderson Hooper's
pretty good Anderson instead of Anderson
Cooper you know cuz I have gray hair
like Anderson Cooper on CNN Anderson
Cooper's a pretty good name for you move
it no no I mean obviously not at all
nope so you just Anderson I don't want
to be gross but you know it could be
something else that rhymes with Hoover
you know Anderson super I can make good
soup
the terrible actually can to make a good
soup I just know I'm too terrible I have
a I have a web series about dinner in a
video game where I try to make dinner
and play video games so I made like
pizza and played The Last of Us it
elastic crust and I burned myself like
50 times it's a mess I gave my food
poisoning no don't ever let me cook food
it was not great
but I put Bagel Bites on it so I put
little pizzas on top so you just see the
big event right exactly so it's like
Pizza inception who is Pizza on peeps so
don't eat the pieces
yes people they eat the little pizzas on
the other pizzas good
Aaron blaze cricket Jonny it's going
great yes if you guys are just Reuters
again we're with dimes out getting your
questions number one draft picks and NBA
2k league which starts may burst follow
him dat boy dimes Twitter and Instagram
and go to NBA 2k league calm to check
out the league and all the teams and I
can't believe it there we go
and yeah May 1st it starts man on
twitch.tv slash NBA 2k league how many
are you just gonna play a game a week
what's your schedule a you know just I
mean just like em yeah you are they try
gonna try to get in more games because
so for the tournament I believe okay
and we just have to play it throughout
the whole bag of the okay there we go
for the regular season so every week
every week alright couple on a frequent
flyer miles on man and you know what
you're gonna be taking your shoes off a
lot of TSA dr. Scholl's should endorse
you because they're gonna steal a lot of
your you know I'm telling you man show
me get on this guy or somebody else does
exactly now I don't even understand this
question
EJ does sniper is asking do you think
post scorers can make the league what
does that mean so post scores architects
so associated Dirk is a pro score
because he likes to do most work out of
the post got it okay it's favor mover
is the post-fader way off the one foot
so he's like a post core god yes post
course and make the lead and that's just
like I said archetype I like it yeah so
they can yes the answer to that is yes I
know I just want to score 30 points
okay that's all I wanted to know don't
let no I shouldn't have told you my
secret secret mission okay that's a good
shot there we okay to say he says this
is twice okay that's fine you know
cockfights UK says times what do you
think will be the biggest challenge in
getting to the championship ourselves
ourselves just get to know each other
whatever and building the chemistry I
mean that's that's the really the
biggest thing was gonna plant yeah not
cracking under pressure and I mean and
this another dumb question slide you
know you guys obviously are gonna be
facing some pretty tough competition you
know right I mean I would imagine yes I
mean cuz obviously it's not just right I
mean hopefully it's all these guys
trying to be friendly
exactly and so you know you might have
to switch up your strategy halfway
through you know so what's Jonah
spreaders where does Jonah come from
your coach
what is his history with 2k how did he
get to be the coaches so the great thing
about that's great I've seen in the lab
does that freak you out a little bit
you're 50 years younger than me so I
don't feel you know I'm a hundred and
eight no that's not you right
oh I would be I don't well you're what
23 right so I would be then so the great
thing about donut is that he actually
comes from the community that's great
and he's been playing a long time so he
knows the game he knows the players he
knows everything there is to know about
2k just like the players do and he can
recognize how the other team what the
other teams are running and I kind of
stopped it it was a perfect there we go
you know I want to make sure everybody
touches the ball I like woman I'm about
yes yeah yeah I'm about in the fairness
and also have a superstition where
everyone on the team has to touch the
ball before I try to score practice
makes perfect
that's a good question I gave Zilla Jay
says at times what's your favorite game
to play other than NBA 2k and do you
feel guilty
if you're playing another game and not
putting in the time on NBA 2k so right
now I would have to say for tonight and
that's probably the most popular need
right now
there's Mark Cuban make you play for
tonight is he same plate no no but
definitely Myanmar gotta play for
tonight I know I love that that would be
great hey so yeah it's like the biggest
the most popular game yeah yeah that's
amazing oh my God my way I'd choose
insane no I love it
who do you find is your toughest
opponent well I think you don't really
know yet who's gonna be your toughest
right do you have any rival personal
rivalries of people besides me in this
game right now we're creating a rivalry
for the ages a robbery that the
community loves hi pup is was actually
the number to pick which is sure I could
imagine was my most competition
okay they which is who the guy just
recently mentioned uh-huh so I would say
that's like what the can we like to see
let us see me him pull up against each
other handy
of course yeah just oh my god and he
museum he's on oh damn oh god it's ugly
Charles oh yeah that's crazy so that's a
matchup to look out for in the coming
season everybody wants to see and when I
did see is he point Garros and who is he
plays the point of course there we go
there we go and it's so funny so we've
done a couple clueless gamers with some
football guys and we'll have a person
from each team you know so we had like
we had Gronk and Marshawn right and but
those guys a lot of times don't know
face each other on the field because one
will play defense all the outfit you
know but it's yeah it's totally
different words you guys are gonna play
each other every game oh oh man I'm
playing a lot of God of War okay it's
great I think yeah they just kinda they
knew what it's the ring oh it's great
I'm a big horror game fan its ps4 yep
and a lot of mothers Sony issues what a
very emotional you know like haha you
know like one of my favorite games of
all time is the last of us have you
played that so I I'm not ashamed to say
that cries it's very emotional much like
I'm gonna do at the end of this game I'm
gonna bleep also because I'm just
getting 26 to 94 is I hope my mom is not
watching this she would lose all respect
for me not that she has anybody I don't
know if you can go into negative respect
but I would get it I would definitely
get it from I love more yeah absolutely
I mean I think for sure oh but yeah I
played Resident Evil and the VR was too
scary for me to play and I and cries Lee
was doing I was but you know then I did
you know because I'm a Camille
and I pay it forward I set up the
virtual reality call a resident evil in
our conference room and had people come
in like hey or play this game and I
scared the [ __ ] out of them and recorded
it but on my phone it was amazing it was
great I'm the worst person cuz we were
literally just talking about it yeah I'm
not a big huh but I will watch for with
somebody who's a scary person hmm
so like a laugh that's that right you're
doing it for your own enjoyment yeah I
love it
when are yours and are they're
pranksters on your team you guys play
pranks at all I mean you guys kind of
just getting to know each other it's
like the first week nobody wants to play
pranks yet cuz nobody wants to get
yelled at but eventually there's gonna
be some pranks being played I can
imagine you guys are all so I think I
think you know as a team you guys are
spending so much time together yeah you
can't hand in the water all that stuff
yeah that's as you're asking for it at
that and locks aren't gonna keep these
guys out you know they work with our
hands their job is with their hands you
think they can't pick a lock or to get
in there come on man yeah but that was
really fun also you know we've been
working together on the show for a long
time and back in New York we worked in
the 30 rock in the building and our
floor was infested with mice just Mike
we're filthy he would be and so I bought
a fake Mouse and everybody thought it
was coming from the office across from
my desk so I bought a fake Mouse got
fishing lines but it this is a good by
the way good praying for you we pray and
I attach it to the mouse and ran it
across the thing under my desk so his
people would walk down the hall I would
jerk it across and be like oh like the
critic scream yeah oh my god oh no this
is before I didn't videotape it
thank God I woulda been fired but the
best thing was my favorite thing was
our executive producer Jeff Ross is the
Iceman he's on touchable like he's just
like so cool calm and collected never
gets your link and you know Conan's like
impression booms like where's the soup
like he only cares about - no I you wash
down the hall keep it right I just got
hired so this is a stupid idea
and I pull the mouse across and everyone
else is screaming news goes a mouse just
point at the Messick there's a mouse can
you scare on the guy is a nice man nice
water in his veins
I feel you you wouldn't get skipped
right would you be scared in the house a
mouse I'm asking for your teammates who
are gonna try to Frank you know so yeah
exactly but that's what scares me
I'm a big guy too they move so fast
times like roaches up so fast
do I near a teammate snore I think he's
too busy pranking up to see if there's
no what system is the illegal maybe a
two case yes everybody I think do you
have your own kid you play with a normal
controller do you have a tricked-out
controller you like so I see how the
stuff controller nice are you I can't
wait for when you come out with your the
Dynes controller oh my god I can't wait
it's got show pads on the sides
[Laughter]
jimena says dimes this very nice manner
well that's because this is an
exhibition game he stop talking smack on
me you know like he's being nice he's
yeah exactly he's taking pity on me this
is this is pitying die
you know this isn't the this isn't
warrior diamonds we're gonna find if you
face him on the court do you have a oh
there we go
do you have a separate account you ever
play with people secretly online as
somebody else not yourself so for me I
would totally love that
I would totally do that and then be like
just like buckets buckets bucketz lost a
true def x biggest robbery fab and
compete yeah you got it but here's the
thing man you gotta have rival that's
the whole point like that's the entire
fans love rise unless they love it so
you got it ya know you gotta feed into
that man you gotta feed into that we're
looking forward to playing the most any
besides fab right I mean I don't know is
there any particular team so do you know
the the the makeups of all the other
teams and who all the other players
former teammates wanna play my boys who
play for the Pacers we actually we're
all teammates this year oh my gosh I
drafted to the same team which is the
Pacers whoa second pick Oh Mike so they
all got shot and you not and you got
padded jacket of the Mavs yeah that goes
to the master hilarious they're the
they're on the Pacers they were wolf
went first well so the Pacers it is he
took this was a second round was
supposed to be he was like my lag now
someone lighting on the finish so he was
like Michael I'm winner this year
oh no so he would actually guard fat
played them so everybody wants to like
always wonder like what happened if wolf
guarded me right so now you get to see
dude I love that oh my god that's gonna
be crazy I love it is Erick we all have
a few more minutes is there like a can
we do like a three-point shootout or
something uh like a quick skill game not
that I
haven't shown my skills already I'd like
exactly we only have a few more minutes
guys to get your question in questions
in four dimes then never the money but
100 man
oh let's do it let's do it so you want
to use what's that you want to use I do
like a sweaty player because that shows
me that they're trying you know like
you're not sweaty what are you doing man
you got it you know so you want to go
Kevin Durant is looking like that's a
moist face I like that that's a very
moist face exactly and also you're too
busy to tell yourself off cuz you're
playing you know you care about you care
about appearances you just want to score
right no definitely all right let's do
it Duran I'm in alright so your Big Papi
rich thoughts and Dallas building a new
eSports facility that's pretty are you
playing in that new eSports facility yes
the practice facility that we are
building we will be playing in the mass
gaming actually released like a preview
of how it's gonna look
whoa so it's gonna be crazy it's gonna
have like a full stage everything - who
you - Kate doesn't intimidate you your
unshakable I would just be like it's
gonna be like your home man it's gonna
be our home I love that good pick your
pick
pick the guy you put that you want the
most that you love the most I mean you
know I don't know or the guy you hate
the most maybe you play your worst enemy
or just this the least sweaty guy the
driest looking guy it's got the least
are you watching the NBA playoff you are
watching NBA Playoffs who do you think
is gonna win exactly well flame low
flame who knows you crazy that the
Cavaliers in a patience matchup but that
[ __ ] crazy like Lance Stephenson is
going crazy and everybody is coming into
everybody's head like they're almost
fighting on the course geez sounds crazy
that makes it that much more interesting
like everybody's tuning in all right
okay here we get so um don't wanna lose
your wingers yeah okay
ringer here we go so when you want let's
do it that's right let's down the street
from here all right there you go now I
like soup yeah so again we are NBA 2k
league starts May 1st on twitch.tv slash
NBA 2k league and follow them to NBA 2k
league on Instagram Twitter and Facebook
of course follow dat boy dimes that boy
the doctor says I'm lookin at you at the
Twitter and Instagram and of course
obviously at Mads Gigi this is your team
follow the squad oh my god oh you know
I'm dumb I'm terrain alright
comfort is smothered exactly huge he
you're a big dude and I feel like oh
look at this Wow also I don't appreciate
you dressing in all white because I feel
like blinding to me you know in the
lights so that was a good size yeah
exactly
alright nice this is just gonna be you
dunking on me a thousand times okay
alright here we go
no wait teach me some moves here what am
i okay so that's okay it was just you at
least it okay got it
so like this little white thing that
pops up right here let me show you it's
the shot time so you want to release
that unless it gets to the very end
okay when it's at its biggest yeah okay
do I have to go get them all that feels
like a little mean so we're gonna get
the ball now so let's get this man is so
sponsorship exactly yeah any tips for
people who want to join the league next
year is there gonna be a similar are you
literally just standing on the side this
is always gonna let you oh that's so
that's somebody that's very nice of you
times it's very nice so tips to make
sure um I don't know if it's gonna be
the same layout or not right because
they just started the league this was
the first time situation but if it is
the same way just just go out there and
showcase your skills the best you can
just play your game that's what else a
new comes down to just playing your game
not getting rattled you're gonna get bad
teammates just prepare for the worst and
do the best you can that's that's the
best tips I could give you yeah and also
you know and be disciplined I would say
you
like you got to this point because you
worked really hard and you put like you
said earlier definitely gotta put the
time yeah let the time in you put the
working man in homeless hours exactly I
think people make the mistake of only
seeing you getting drafted and be like
oh my god you know like instead of what
they don't see is the hours and hours
and hours of work you're putting in by
yourself you know and you know you
taking the time to critique yourself get
better things that you're not good at
and you know really challenge yourself
and oh there we go
this but ya know I think that people
always see the bright lights but they
never want to see you know the work that
goes into the bright lights which is
great of course cuz now even though you
know like you were talking about you
guys are everyday practicing like a team
and going in you know and making
adjustments you know which is what you
have to do is knowing everything to
build chemistry exactly that's the
biggest name totally I love you oh man I
didn't do I was just like did it you
know what it was no hi I had a weird I
had a weird like hand tremor and then it
just did the thing I love that show have
you seen hard knocks on HBO that follows
the pre-season of a football team okay
and you know before the season starts
and I love that show because it's very
much you know it's them watching tape
and it's them oh that's a bad shot yeah
and I think that you know again like a
lot of people don't realize what it
takes to get to your level you know
which is really cool
I mean you don't just get to be this
good at anything without practice now
you can the the reverse of that is you
can be as bad as me by putting in no
time so yeah if you want to be as bad as
I am don't put any time into it then you
will be is literally a piece of garbage
at this game which is me and you'll get
lucky because the game will take pity on
you and the algorithm will say alright
let's give him one shot so exactly how
you feel my dev not making the league
feel like there should have made it he's
a proven winner he made it he actually
made it to the finals in the
championship that I won last year so I
mean to get that far you got to be
someone yeah absolutely is definitely a
top player he should definitely be here
he'd be here next year there we go never
got it I know that's the thing is that
you know they're not just doing this for
one year so yeah definitely Roger Rabbit
asks are you guys nervous times doesn't
get nervous I don't want to speak for
you when was the last time you were
nervous so yeah like I said at the draft
just like just anticipation I love like
a bajillion summers there like like it's
Wiimote the biggest stager like I'm a
little nervous it's just like it was
it's just like sitting there yeah
knowing your name must be cod just
waiting just waiting
what did you wear what did you wear and
sloshy wore a suit a blue suit nice I
love it blue suit my both sides actually
fire you in both eyes so yeah I did did
you have everybody weigh in on your on
your Duma stylist I mean did you have
myself well actually move your friends
when my brother came he'd be addicting
so you actually make homie my brother my
uncle I love for any important event
I'll bring in like four outfits in to
work we'll do like a fashion show and
Beth always gives me Tom the truth all
right so where he's like no that that's
that's don't don't do that
she's like no even like down to the
watch like I'll have like all the people
where cuz I don't know anything like
what am i doing I always wear like a
dumb t-shirt who there's a good big
Bobby Roode ties are you guys gonna get
jerseys and Kenneth fans buy them do you
know I don't know do you know the merch
situation besides your doctor Scholl's
endorsement um yeah we're so we're gonna
get jerseys and yes there's right here
which is actually very fire this is
great look at that man this yesterday I
was so high I also I loved it I love
like the I'm wearing it everywhere dude
that's fantastic fire yeah and this is
by the way a quality this is like a dry
fit this is a quality quality Jersey
that's awesome thousand did you have fun
in NYC for the drive was there your
first time in New York no so I had been
there pretty
a few times awesome let's say around I'm
sure that helps with the nervousness -
like having been India if that was your
first time in New York also one of those
big buildings you probably hope yeah
yeah a lot of fun
the after-party was though it was very
fun what's a someplace something like a
club that's I love also the fact like
it's a defense of joint venture between
the NBA and 2k is [ __ ] it's crazy back
it's legit that's the real that's the
real thing that's why I say like those
that's the limit that's right you know
what oh this is interesting game Loic
says times whether you like it or not
you set the bar for this league and a
community comes that target on your back
whoo not not only in the league but
every aspiring player as well you feel
it pressure the entire community chasing
after you
so I've been pretty used to that by the
way that's a very also very nice
compliment that's extreme that's a great
question but also that's a really result
as well so I'm sort of my saying I
appreciate that yeah and I've been oh
you know I'm like one of the most hated
players so that yeah it just comes with
the territory so I'm just unprepared I
was prepared for it and I'm ready for it
yeah I mean you know and I think hey are
you it must be interesting because like
giving interviews and like being
interviewed like that's a skill as well
which is kind of like comes with the
territory of being number one it's got
to be like navigating that whole thing
it's a different world right yeah I mean
you seem like incredibly you're way more
relaxed than I am and I like to live I
sleep on this couch yeah I shower in the
props Department I sleep on this couch
exactly yeah it's pretty good actually
this is our couch in New York so who's
sat here Bill Clinton sat here on this
yeah in this couch literally you're
sitting yeah you shared but space with
Bill Clinton there you go Ryan Reynolds
right I guess couch yeah Deadpool
actually laying right oh he's the man
yeah nicest dude
the world is the greatest so he's nice
yeah everybody Clinton also very nice
all that didn't really talk to the but
yeah man it's it's interested in now
you're on this you're on a stage you're
on a main stage I got ten points how did
it you're just not even what you're just
letting me well it goes back and forth
very nice like I said you're you're
navigating the diplomacy of interviews
very well I love it now that's very sad
that's great I love like it's kind of
interesting to and very flattering that
they're built they built a whole
practice facility and stuff for you guys
because it's very though oh wow I see my
own thing and you know Matt's like you
know what a good idea with that note
said put essentially put us on a live
stage so I'm pretty sure it's preparing
us yeah I'm getting I'm guessing you'll
probably get to go to Mavs games and
stuff I mean Rex it's it's you are on
the Mavs team of course all that is all
that this goes without saying that comes
goes without saying I love it oh that's
so cool to go yeah yeah for sure I mean
they they led us into a conan taping but
we have to pay daily I'm just kidding
the audience is free
oh my god well that was I'm not gonna
say it wasn't embarrassing but it was
nursing uh dives thank you so much this
is fantastic once again follow a dime's
dat boy dimes on Twitter and Instagram
that bully
dat boy follow the maps at Mavs GG
Twitter Instagram all those good things
and Facebook of course and follow NBA 2k
league Twitter Instagram and of course
watch the premiere of the NBA 2k league
May 1st first twitch.tv slash NBA 2k
league thank you guys for joining us
thank you - once again let's give him a
hand
thank you guys watch this guy's I think
he's going places he's been places and
he's going places and faces in Oakland
and we will see you guys next week see
you later